[Music]
in October 2017 we finally had the
chance to follow the story of an openly
gay teenager for the new season of Andy
Mack on Disney Channel it is the first
time that Disney is really going to talk
about some LGBTQ issues but queerness
has been a part of Disney for a long
time and this is what we are going to
take a look at today make sure you watch
this video until the end to know why
parents wanted to ban frozen if you love
Disney as much as we do don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up today we are showing you
Disney's long complicated history with
gay characters Disney's history with gay
characters is not as recent as you might
think
LGBTQ characters have been part of the
Disney family since only a few years
after it was founded at that time the
characters were not openly gay but they
were clearly queer meaning that they
were outside the usual heterosexual norm
the word queer can also be an umbrella
term for the LGBT community as it
represents lesbians gays bisexuals and
transgenders according to Sean Griffin
who wrote Tinkerbell's and Evil Queen's
the Walt Disney Company from the inside
out and as reported by her purse bizarre
it was often possible to read queer
narratives between the lines the
homosexuals weren't really accepted at
that time Disney needed to find a way to
show someone who is different without
making him too different it all started
with the short film Ferdinand the bull
in 1938 the eight-minute film was
inspired by Monroe leaves the story of
Ferdinand it told the story of a bull
who didn't conform to the expectations
of masculinity oh the other bulls wanted
to fight while Ferdinand just wanted to
sit quietly under a tree to smell the
flowers all day even when he grew up to
be huge and was forced to fight in
Madrid he was too distracted by the
scent of the flowers to do anything the
sweet bull also had long eyelashes and
many other feminine characteristics
making him really different compared to
the other masculine bulls Disney won an
Oscar for the best animated short so we
can say that people really did
appreciate queer characters at that time
even though they probably didn't even
know what that word meant
then in 1941 we also saw The Reluctant
dragon when a boy heard that there was a
dragon he decided to meet him and
quickly realize that this mythical
creature was actually really nice the
dragon loved poetry and music and was
also very friendly compared to the
monster that the boy saw in his book a
knight wanted to get rid of this scary
creature when the
I heard about that he made sure that the
man and the dragon wouldn't hurt each
other while people thought that they
were fighting they were actually just
drinking tea or dancing together the
dragon is a great example of how men
don't have to conform to heterosexual
standards or any masculine
characteristic the society expects them
to have people are scared of what they
don't know and The Reluctant dragon
showed them that unique people could be
really nice when you take the time to
get to know them it was a good story to
teach children how to accept differences
and not judge a book by its cover
unfortunately in 1930 came a code that
was going to change everything about the
queer characters the motion picture
production code always known as the Hays
Code prohibited sex perversion or any
inference as reported by Harper's Bazaar
films could only present correct
standards of life and nudity and
references to sexual behaviors couldn't
be shown just to make it even more clear
that they didn't like queer people what
they consider to be perverse like
homosexuality couldn't be depicted in
any way the code was seriously enforced
in 1943 and had more impact during the
1940s since that day any male character
with more feminine characteristics had
to be portrayed as evil in 1953 s Peter
Pan Captain Hook was a prissy dandy
dressed in bright pink who liked to prey
on young boys it encouraged the
stereotype that homosexuals are
predators interested in children
following this idea filmmaker David
Thorpe was interested in the gay voice
that Disney often gave to villains in do
I sound gay Thorpe told Harper's Bazaar
that some feminine characteristics shows
that there was something a little bit
off with these characters it included
Jafar from Aladdin in 1992 and scar from
The Lion King in 1994 for decades Disney
films have reinforced the stereotypes
the gay men are bad because not only do
they scheme and enact mischief upon the
good characters but they are also bad
because they don't conform to cultural
norms of gender the filmmaker then
started describing queer characters who
are flamboyant use flowery language pay
a lot of attention how they dress and
have a very snobbish way of speaking
this was a stereotype and not all gay
men are like that
but Disney still wanted to use this gay
stereotype to represent the villains in
many movies this time being different
was a bad thing and they had to teach
children to not go too far from the
heterosexual norms
however during this time Disney still
had the chance to sneak in a queer
character in The Little Mermaid in 1989
can you guess who it is some people said
that Ursula was actually inspired by
drag-queen called divine they made sure
that the octopus was really born female
in the film but we still love to think
that the character was inspired by one
of the most fabulous women out there
back to Disney's gay villains you might
be surprised that they still made fun of
queer characters recently in 2012
wreck-it Ralph we say another gay
villain while Ralph the hero was a
really tough masculine guy King candy
was wearing a fancy outfit and lived in
a pink palace the character would
quickly reply that it's not pink it's
salmon as if it would be bad for a man
to live in a pink palace it's not that
bad or we mean we are used to seeing
that but then we were totally shocked
when we heard Ralph's called a candy
King a Nelly wafer we understand that it
is like an alley wafer but when we look
for the definition of Nelly on Google we
read that it means an effeminate
homosexual man how did Disney get away
with that there is clearly a homophobic
slang in this movie and even if kids
don't know what it means they probably
won't be shy to use this word and hurt
people who understand it we should never
tolerate the use of a word like this in
a kid's movie Disney was more popular
than ever in 2013 with frozen don't
worry we love this movie just as much as
you do Elsa was a princess or actually a
queen who didn't need a man the only
thing she was looking for was the love
of her sister and the strength to accept
who she truly was but some people
imagined another story when they heard
her sing let it go according to them
this story was about coming out of the
closet after all she did talk about
always being a good girl who wouldn't
let people see who she truly was I don't
care what they're going to say let the
storm rage on the cold never bothered me
anyway
this could totally be the perfect lyrics
for coming out many fans wanted Elsa to
finally find her princess even though we
are really happy to see a queen who
doesn't mind living on her own but
unfortunately not everyone liked to see
a character that could be queer in a
Disney movie
pastor Kevin Samson called frozen the
work of evil according to what he said
on the show Disney indoctrinate young
women to be lesbians and also convinces
people that homosexuality and bestiality
are acceptable in our society he also
thinks that people rejected their queen
because they realized that she was a
lesbian
Katherine Skaggs a Mormon blogger also
thought that frozen normalized
homosexuality
she wrote the words to let it go are
clearly
Christian values friendly by any stretch
of the imagination when understood and
hurt this is not an innocent song with a
catchy tune it is rebellious it mocks
moral absolutes it is careless
that's what Katherine said we think that
if loving yourself is wrong we don't
want to be right however we think that
they see gay propaganda in anything
writers from the LGBTQ community even
said that Disney probably didn't intend
to make Elsa a queer character but it
happened and we should celebrate it if
there is one thing that we don't like
about the idea of Elsa being gay it is
that people assume that she's a lesbian
just because she doesn't have a print
they don't seem to think that a girl
would like to be happy on her own and if
she becomes a homosexual that's probably
because a man is missing in her life
moreover they didn't even consider that
she could be bisexual pansexual or
simply queer we don't agree with this
idea and we'd rather keep this story
like it is as long as we don't know
Elsa's sexual orientation people can
interpret it in their favorite way and
that's what we love about art let Elsa
be a lesbian if that's a good
inspiration for you but let her be
single if that's what you prefer it's
only in 2014 in good luck charlie that
we really had the chance to see a
lesbian couple in this episode Bob and
Amy we're talking about who was coming
over for a playdate with their daughter
Charlie Amy said that the kid's mom was
named Susan while Bob said that he met
her too but her name was Cheryl did they
accidentally invite two different kids
we were all surprised when they opened
the door and we realized that there were
actually two moms who had a kid together
Disney knew that this episode could be
controversial this is why they decided
to develop the storyline under the
consultancy of child development experts
and community advisors and like Disney
Channel programming it was developed to
be relevant to kids and families around
the world and to reflect themes of
diversity and inclusiveness however not
everyone was happy with this decision
the group 1 Million Moms wrote that just
because something may be legal or
because some are choosing a lifestyle
doesn't make it morally correct no
matter what many people defended the
show and Disney didn't regret their
decision two years after in Zootopia
Disney did show a gay couple but it was
really subtle in this movie Judy's
neighbors are really loud but if you
paid attention to them as they entered
their apartment you will notice that
they were two different male antelopes
they are not seen together but we can
assume that they are a married couple as
they live together
moreover in the film's credits they are
listed as bucky oryx antler sin and
Pronk Oryx and Larssen when we look at
their last name it is pretty clear that
these two are married that's not enough
to shock parents even though they
shouldn't be shocked at all but it is
nice enough to show a little bit of
diversity in 2017 we finally had the
chance to see a gay character in Beauty
and the Beast and that's not even just
one possible interpretation Disney
really wanted to show more diversity the
director Bill Condon even said that he
would see the first Disney exclusively
gay moment in his movie this gay
character was the food
Gaston's best friend or manservant bill
explained that Lefou on one day wants to
be guest on and on another day wants to
kiss Gaston Lefou is clearly in love
with the villain and even if Gaston is
not really interested in him he doesn't
reject him either during another scene
madame garderobe attacked three men by
dressing them up like ladies two of them
ran away but another one really liked
this look it was great to see a man who
was not afraid to show his feminine side
later in Beauty and the Beast Lefou was
also seen dancing with another man it
was really subtle but we did see it this
is not a lot but we are still really
happy to see the Disney made an effort
but once again some people thought that
it was a step too far
in some countries like Malaysia people
wanted to ban this game omit they said
that it is only one short scene but it
is inappropriate because many children
will be watching this movie however they
said that they would screen the scene
without this game moment Disney refused
saying that they wouldn't cut this scene
and the first openly gay character will
remain in the movie if you think that it
only happens in other countries you will
be surprised to hear that a movie
theater in Alabama wanted to ban Beauty
and the Beast - they said on their
Facebook page if we cannot take our 11
year-old granddaughter and
eight-year-old grandson to see a movie
we have no business watching it if I
can't sit through a movie with God or
Jesus sitting by me then we have no
business showing it but Disney didn't
care and they stood up for what they
thought was right it is in 2017 in and
eMac that we finally got the chance to
see a whole disney story about an openly
gay character and his knee channel for
the second season of the show we will
follow a group of friends and he has a
crush on Jonah but her best friend Cyrus
will quickly realize that he has
feelings for Jonah - Cyrus will get the
help of a friend who will be there to
support him and we hope that it will be
a great role model for teenagers the
story was developed with child
development experts and screened in
advance with organiz
Asians like Common Sense Media is glad
and PFLAG so parents wouldn't have to
worry we can't wait to see what will
happen to this character so make sure
you watch this TV show if you haven't
yet we think that the next step is
making a Disney movie with two princes
how would you like to see more diversity
on screen make sure you answer in the
comment section down below
we love to hear what you think and
that's it for Disney's long complicated
history with gay characters for more
stories like this make sure you watch 10
strange reasons why Disney movies were
banned thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]